[Musique]
il porte des noms tels que solarwinz
stocksnet ou Ana Cry vol des données
espionne et sa botte des systèmes ils
infectent et paralysent des entreprises
des administrations voire des états ces
virus informatiques sont peut-être les
nouvelles armes des conflits
d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
les cyberattaques font de plus en plus
souvent là une de l'actualité comme le
montre les événements récents en Europe
la menace est réelle faut-il pour autant
oublier les fusils d'assaut et les chars
blindés la guerre sera-t-elle bientôt
cyber
[Musique]
la cyberguerre c'est à la fois une
réalité et à la fois il y a un côté un
petit peu
mythe en fait aujourd'hui il y aura des
actions dans cyberespace ça c'est une
évidence ça fait de nombreuses années
que ça existe que ce soit contre les
institutions donc contre les forces
armées ou leur capacité mais aussi
contre contre les individus et on le
voit bien avec la guerre en Ukraine des
actions qui peuvent éventuellement être
considérées comme des actions de guerre
ou en tout cas dans un environnement de
guerre existe les Ukrainiens subissent
des accidents depuis très nombreuses
années des attaques qui sont malgré tout
assez handicapantes en fait pour un
certain nombre de de leurs capacité de
leurs institutions
dans l'imaginaire collectif ce qu'on
appelle cyberespace c'est Internet le
monde virtuel la réalité est un peu plus
complexe cet espace immense et sans
frontières est créée par
l'interconnexion des réseaux
informatiques mondiaux il est fait de
trois couches principales une couche
physique celle des infrastructures
matérielles qui lui permettent d'exister
comme les câbles les serveurs ou les
ordinateurs une couche logique celle du
langage informatique qui permet aux
machines de communiquer entre elles
comme les protocoles ou les codes et une
couche dite informationnelle qui
regroupe le contenu présent sur le web
chacune de ces couches peut être
cyber-attaquée dans la première les
câbles sous-marins par exemple qui
transportent la quasi-totalité des
communications mondiales sont parfois la
cible d'acte de malveillance de
dégradation ou d'espionnage
le numérique a aujourd'hui conquis la
planète et le monde militaire n'y
échappe pas aujourd'hui oui le ministère
des armées est performant parce qu'il
est numérisé et donc parce qu'il est
numérisé il doit développer des
capacités de cybersécurité de cyberf
défense des mécanismes qui vont
permettre de protéger de défendre nos
systèmes d'informations pour assurer la
résilience des forces armées le
fonctionnement du ministère
le cyber c'est pas juste un guide
derrière un ordinateur c'est
véritablement une manœuvre militaire
conçue dans sa complexité dans ses
interactions avec les autres acteurs
opérationnels quand il y a une attaque
pour nous c'est une opération de défense
en fait on va défendre nos capacité
opérationnelles nos intérêts militaires
le commandement de la cyber défense
classe les opérations dans le
cyberespace en trois domaines de lutte
informatique
défensive offensive
[Musique]
et d’influence
quant au premier domaine celui de la
cyberdéfense à proprement parler il
regroupe toutes les mesures de
protection des moyens informatiques
employés pour assurer la défense de
notre pays
à Toulon la frégate de défense aérienne
Chevalier Paul est à quai pour un arrêt
technique
l'industriel est à bord pour tester les
systèmes
[Musique]
reçu 32 36
au centrale opération le second maître
Emma détecte une anomalie
classifiés hostiles papa 01 dans le 90
piste classifiées au style un bâtiment
hostile approche mais le système d'armes
ne répond plus
impossible de passer au Para manœuvrer
le lanceur 3 est en erreur
on va investiguer bug ou incident
technique plus que ça une attaque cyber
en réalité une fausse attaque cyber
jouer lors de l'édition 2022 Death Note
l'exercice annuel de la cyberdéfense
française l'occasion d'entraîner toute
la chaîne cyber du ministère 14 états
majors direction et services sont
mobilisés soit plusieurs centaines de
cybercombattants des trois armées sur le
pied de guerre pour jouer plusieurs
dizaines de scénaristes
qui est notre système interne donc on
peut en déduire que la faute elle
viendrait d'en bas après encore une fois
j'ai simplement constaté le lanceur
numéro 3 en faute et j'ai pas plus
d'informations à vous donner une menace
va exploiter une vulnérabilité pour
tenter de produire un impact
opérationnel par exemple un attaque
températurenel force et une cyberata qui
s'en prend à nos radars et qui vont les
bloquer les empêcher de détecter une
attaque potentielle ou de même une
attaque là aussi théorique et bien
évidemment on s'empoie ce que ces
attaques ne puissent pas se faire qu'on
puisse les détecter les empêcher mais
par exemple sur le porte-avion que le
système qui permet aux avions de
décoller n'existe plus parce qu'il a été
bloqué ou bloqué les communications
satellitaires donc c'est à dire que nos
forces de payer en opération non plus
les moyens de communiquer ça c'est un
impact opérationnel fort donc c'est pour
ça justement que on a véritablement un
besoin d'être très paranoïaque et de
s'intéresser à tous les types d'attaque
et donc à toutes les motivations
possibles et imaginables
c'est l'objectif de Death Note
s'entraîner à détecter analyser et
contrer toute menace cyber l'exercice
est piloté par le commandement de la
cyberdéfense à partir de sa base à
Rennes
c'est un exercice dont la préparation
dure environ un an parce qu'elle y
rassemble comme je vous l'ai dit un
certain nombre d'entités qui sont très
diverses cette année dans le cadre du
scénario nous sommes confrontés à une
menace de nature étatique qui a pour
objectif d'entraver l'action des armées
à la fois en opération extérieure et sur
le territoire national on a un travail
très important qui est qui porte sur le
réalisme de l'exercice et on essaye
autant que possible de jouer ces
attaques réellement contre nos systèmes
et de jouer également la phase de
restauration
qui nous permet de retrouver l'intégrité
de nos systèmes en réel
[Musique]
à Mont-de-Marsan un incident cyber et
simulé sur un système solaire moyenne
porté Mamba qui permet de sécuriser
l'espace aérien
et c'est bon j'ai bien les munitions sur
le théor
celui à Lise le bug
les lieutenant marine et sur place avec
son GIC son groupe d'intervention cyber
donc si vous voulez bien m'expliquer ce
qui s'est passé c'est bien qui avait vu
l'incident ce matin exactement en fait
ces équipes d'experts interviennent en
cas d'incidence cyber
ique
je l'ai branché directement au lanceur
en fait au lanceur c'est à partir du
moment où vous l'avez mangé vous avez
lancé des manips dessus et ensuite ça
s'est déclenché exactement et donc là
depuis ça
un peu comme des inspecteurs ou des
médecins légistes ils investissent la
scène de l'incident pour enquêter
et donc vous m'avez dit que vous avez
trouvé un marqueur de compromission
voilà donc c'est un fichier que vous
avez retrouvé
pas de mon interne chez MBDA donc
effectivement il semble être suspect ils
sont parfois renforcés par l'industriel
concepteur du système attaqué
autant pour pour ressortir vraiment tout
le caractère malveillant
de l'exécutable
sur la base aéronavale de Hyères le
scénario est transverse il touche deux
hélicoptères NH90 Cayman terre et Marine
les instruments de bord qui donnent le
cap sont défaillants
quelque chose qui ressort du coup
et bien écoutez mon capitaine au vu du
déchargement des données de vol de notre
vol il n'y a aucune remontée
significative
qui concerne la dérive des Caps que nous
avons eu pendant le vol
aucun code panne
je ne comprends pas j'ai essayé sur
l'autre logiciel pareil aucune remontée
de panne
de vaisseau Vincent et son équipe sont
dépêchés sur place
c'est d'essayer de voir d'abord deux
choses le premier c'est de d'établir une
timeline claire du coup de de ce que ce
qui était remarqué quand on arrive sur
sur les lieux l'objectif pour nous ça va
être de déterminer en fait le périmètre
donc c'est à dire l'ensemble de des
systèmes qui ont pu être touchés par par
l'attaque c'est pour ça qu'on procède
d'abord à un interrogatoire et un
dialoguant avec différents intervenants
à la fois des industriels à la fois des
du personnel technique qui a l'habitude
d'intervenir sur la machine et les
personnes qui habitent de la conduire
juste avant de revenir on s'est rendu
compte en fait qu'il y avait une dérive
de 15 degrés sur les nos deux IRS on
avait un cap affiché au 148 pour une
piste au 133 on est rentré au parc on a
coupé on a déchargé la machine donc la
mécanicien navigant a déchargé le le
rapport du vol et en fait on a eu aucun
problème pour monter donc c'est vraiment
un IRS c'est la partie qui vous donne le
cap c'est ça c'est la les centres
universel
j'imagine et tous les paramètres de vol
ok d'accord ensuite on procède à une
partie prélèvement donc l'objectif ça va
être de faire des relevés du contenu de
la mettre des différents sites
d'informations et en tirer du coup des
images qu'on pourra après analyser dans
avec des outils spécifiques que nous
possédons
direction Toulon au centre support cyber
dont dépend Vincent pour l'analyse des
données donc l'objectif ça va être de
avec les images qu'on a faites des
systèmes qu'on a quand on était prélevés
hier on va maintenant les analyser les
décortiquer pour essayer de comprendre
le malware son chemin et remonter ce
chemin là et après avoir qu'est-ce
qu'elle est la zone qui était polluée et
comment ensuite la dépolluer et nettoyer
le système pour le rendre opérationnel
vous avez fait tout à fait en facecam
est agréé sur IAS des fenêtres c'est
aussi l'entraînement des noms
spécialistes car les opérateurs sur le
terrain sont parmi les premiers
confrontés à une potentielle attaque
le centre support cyber entraîne les
marins sur une plateforme avant de les
former en mer en conditions réelles
on y retrouve le maître principal Morgan
entraîneur cyberdéfense ici on va
entraîner de l'automaticien de une
personne qui a plus tendance à venir de
de
la branche électricité ou mécanique qui
est pas forcément ou qui est même pas du
tout informaticien à la base c'est parce
qu'on recherche l'idée c'est de le
mettre face à des éléments qui connaît
et de lui apprendre ou de l'entraîner
sur les éléments cybers qui pourraient
s'ajouter à son métier à lui principal
donc là on est concrètement sur la
partie halieutie numérisation du métier
propulsion d'une frégate orientation de
la frégate etc notre méthode
d'entraînement elle a fait ses preuves
l'ensemble des marins sont habitués à
les utiliser il s'agit de à la fois dans
un premier temps détecter l'incident je
suis capable de comprendre ce qui se
passe ensuite je vais le classifier
est-ce que c'est grave est-ce que c'est
pas grave et ensuite on passe dans les
phases de contrées de restaurer ou là le
marin doit être autonome parce qu'il est
sur un bâtiment de surface parce qu'il
est sur un sous-marin parce qu'il est
dans un aéronef il est au centre d'un
conflit il doit être autonome dans ses
actions de remédiation et ses actions de
contre à Rennes les participants doivent
faire face à des crises simulées sur les
réseaux du ministère déployés sur le
territoire national et un opération
d'admin
en gros le truc est complètement
verroulé on peut plus compter dessus
pour ce qui nous concerne du coup on
passe cette fois plus sur une phase
d'investigation à chaud en vue de faire
de la remédiation mais sur une phase
d'investigation un peu plus à froid ou
le but ça va être de comprendre le
cheminement de l'attaquant et d'essayer
de faire émerger ses intentions au
travers des actions parmi eux la 807e
compagnie de transmission une unité à
vocation interarmée spécialisée dans la
lutte informatique ça vous question est
d'apporter en fait une supervision au
système informatique qui sont déployés
en opération le but étant en fait de
pouvoir
faire son appel en anglais du monitoring
donc de la surveillance en permanence de
détecter ce qui sort de la norme pour
pouvoir après éventuellement en
qualifier des incidents et si c'est le
cas après déterminer si on est sous le
coût d'une attaque ou pas le seul que
vous voyez derrière est impliqué dans la
supervision d'une partie des réseaux qui
sont joués sur des fenêtres réseau une
partie des réseaux qui justement simule
un réseau d'opérations donc on se met
dans le contexte dans lequel on va être
amené à servir en opération extérieure
bientôt
parce que le numérique est parti
prenante de tout on a besoin que chaque
exercice et son volet cyber et en tout
cas qu'il est pas un volet à part que ce
soit un volet complètement intégré parce
qu'aujourd'hui dans le cadre des
opérations en fait le cyber est intégré
dans les opérations en fait donc plus ou
moins de manière importante mais il n'y
a pas une opération aujourd'hui qui
n'intègre pas le volet le volet cyber et
donc au même titre qu'il y a un volet
terre RER spatial force spéciale et bien
voilà le cyber est intégré donc tout
exercice se doit aujourd'hui de le faire
il est fondamental de s'entraîner dans
les conditions les plus proches de la
réalité parce qu'aujourd'hui nous
pourrions être exposés face à des
adversaires beaucoup plus entraînés
beaucoup plus agressif et disposant de
moyens d'action beaucoup plus large que
ceux auxquels nous faisons face
actuellement qui sera en mesure de
réaliser des actions offensives à ou à
des fins de renseignement et qui
pourraient perturber la conduite des
opérations
va l'empêcher
c'est bien la finalité des exercices
comme des fenêtres plus performant sur
les théâtres d'opérations partout où la
France est engagée comme en Afrique ou
au Proche-Orient dans le cadre des
opérations barkhane et chamall ou la
807e compagnie est projetée
le théâtre barkham est particulièrement
vaste il fait la taille de l'Europe et
pour contrôler l'ensemble des données
qui sont sur plusieurs pays en Afrique
c'est une équipe donc du coup de cinq
personnes qui sont réparties dans le
socle n'djaminas qui vont pouvoir
contrôler grâce à des sondes réparties
sur l'ensemble des pays tous les flux
qui sont qui transitent par le réseau un
réseau dense mais surtout stratégique
pervisons un parc informatique
conséquent qui représente à peu près
2500 ordinateurs
avec un réseau de télécommunications
assez dense et auxquelles s'ajoute
dernièrement le la supervision des
téléphones mobiles il y a énormément de
manipulations sur sur les ordinateurs ce
qui remonte énormément d'événements mais
ce qui est tout à fait normal
une ouverture de cession le branchement
d'une clé USB l'équipe analyse ses
événements informatiques pour en isoler
les actions suspectes
[Musique]
concrètement une journée représente
environ plusieurs millions d'événements
ce qui représente une vingtaine d'alerte
et de ces vingtaines d'alerte en
découlent un ou deux incidents
journaliers
grâce aux équipements qu'on déploie sur
les différents sites on a des sondes et
ces sons de la loi analyser du coup tout
ce qui se passe elles vont capturer le
flux de système donc ce qui concerne les
ordinateurs en eux-mêmes mais aussi les
flux réseaux c'est réseaux sont des
réseaux protégés sur lesquels circulent
les informations sensibles et on va
regarder ce qui transit comme
information dessus généralement on est
plutôt vu comme les policiers justement
des réseaux mais nous on sait très bien
que on agit pour eux pour la protection
de leur donner et surtout pour que la
mission puisse bien se dérouler
il est intéressant de noter que cette
supervision ne serait pas possible
depuis la métropole la masse de données
est absolument considérable à traiter et
analyser ce serait impossible de leur
rapatrier en France pour des questions
de réseau de débit c'est pour ça qu'il
est important d'être présent sur le
théâtre pour pouvoir le faire
correctement et avec une masse critique
de données suffisante mais également
pour pouvoir conseiller le chef au plus
près et pas par téléphone ou par visio
de depuis la France d'autre part si il y
avait un réel incidence cyber qui s'est
détecté il est probable que les flux
vers la métropole seraient coupés pour
éviter que une attaque se diffuse sur
l'ensemble du réseau cela rendrait la
métropole totalement aveugle et le
théâtre isolé soit justifie le besoin
d'avoir du spécialiste cyber directement
sur place au plus près des chefs la
transformation numérique en cours va
offrir des moyens d'action inédites sur
le champ de bataille comme la mise en
réseau des systèmes d'armes avec pour
conséquence une plus grande efficacité
opérationnelle mais également une plus
grande vulnérabilité la Direction
générale de l'armement experts
techniques du ministère des armées en
matière de cyberdéfense de
l'anticipation de la menace à la
maîtrise d'ouvrage de cybersolution elle
permet aux armées de disposer de
systèmes d'armes cybersécurisés au bon
niveau et de moyens pour mener à bien
les luttes informatiques les notions de
déconnexion est tout à fait illusoire
d'un système d'armes est connecté en
permanence à une quantité d'autres
acteurs et les attaquants en face le
savent parfaitement pourrait vouloir
profiter de l'ensemble de ces connexions
pour venir pénétrer intruser le système
en question c'est le cas par exemple du
Griffon ou du jaguar des blindés de la
gamme scorpion
numérisation accrue de l'ensemble des
véhicules des échanges accrus entre ces
différents pièces sur le terrain on
accro à la surface d'attaque et donc on
est obligé de prendre dès le départ le
plus grand compte de des exigences hiver
l'enjeu pour nous c'est de désormais ne
plus avoir aucun système d'armes qui
puisse être engagé dans un environnement
numérique agressif sans disposer d'un
système de supervision de la sécurité de
détection d'attaque les prochaines
capacités des armées intègreront une
protection numérique dès leur conception
et tout au long de leur cycle de vie
c'est le cas par exemple de la future
frégate de défense et d'intervention
premier programme nativement
cybersécurisé mais le principe de
continuité du cyberespace permet
d'atteindre une cible sans l'attaquer
directement il existe bien souvent un
chemin numérique entre le port et le
bateau en mer entre la station de
carburant et le véhicule
on a tendance à explique cette manière
extrêmement simple en disant que la
sécurité c'est l'affaire de tous les
attaques commencent bien souvent par des
erreurs d'inattention ou des erreurs
individuelles de celui qui branche la
clé USB sur le mauvais système ou clic
sur un lien ou une pièce jointe sans
avoir préalablement cette demander si
cette pièce jointe ou ce lien est de
confiance
du centre DGA maîtrise de l'information
située à Bruz en Bretagne en sont bien
conscients au quotidien ils analysent la
menace et spécifient les architectures
de nos systèmes d'armes pour qu'il
résiste à toute forme d'agressions cyber
il crée aussi des outils de
sensibilisation
ici dans ce scénario un marin reçoit sur
son adresse professionnelle un courriel
avec un document pièce jointe la
plaquette d'information d'un club de
plongée une activité dont il est un
adepte il le télécharge sur sa clé USB
sans se douter qu'il est piégé
l'attaquant la cible est depuis le
réseau LinkedIn où il a trouvé
suffisamment d'informations personnelles
pour préparer son attaque une fois la
clé USB branchée à bord du bateau le
virus va infecter le réseau et prendre
le contrôle du système de propulsion
[Musique]
la cyberdéfense c'est aussi et surtout
un sport collectif voici la défense elle
concerne l'ensemble des acteurs des
utilisateurs du numérique chacun est
responsable justement d'une bonne
utilisation du numérique après c'est
complexe donc on a besoin des
spécialistes de la technologie de
l'informatique des réseaux mais aussi
des réseaux sociaux des acteurs du
renseignement d'intérêt militaire ou
d'autres types de renseignement sur la
sécurité et la défense qui eux aussi
vont contribuer à ce que l'on puisse
couvrir le spectre le plus large
possible à l'intérieur du ministère mais
aussi à l'extérieur avec notamment nos
industriels de la défense qui est aussi
doivent être protégés et ne doivent pas
être des sources de vulnérabilité pour
nous une large part des cyberattacles se
joue sur le terrain économique pour
voler des renseignements des secrets de
fabrication des éléments de recherche et
développement le ministère des armées
est donc particulièrement attentif à ses
partenaires notamment aux 4000
entreprises de la base industrielle et
technologique de défense
en cas de suspicion de compromission
d'une entreprise la Direction du
renseignement et de la sécurité de la
défense la drsd peut décider
d'intervenir
pour des raisons de sécurité l'ensemble
des personnes filmées est anonymisées
d'un point de vue cyber la société
sunlique fait l'objet de plusieurs
tentatives d'intrusion dans ces systèmes
d'information et très récemment d'une
tentative d'escroquerie très organisée
parfait merci pour ce point de situation
c'est incident revêt de dimensions une
dimension économique et une dimension
contingence donc il est il doit être
pris au sérieux
au regard des effectifs disponibles en
direction zone
nous allons apporter une un renfort donc
à partir de la direction centrale donc
deux hypothèses on prend la photographie
de la situation et on mesure à quel
point l'attaque est avancée
ensuite on le hissait est chargé de
mettre fin à cette attaque et enfin
partir du moment où les résultats sont
conformes aux attendus donc on est
revenu à une situation
nominale il faut reconstruire le système
d'information s'assurer que l'attaquant
n'est plus présent sur le système
d'information le service à ce moment-là
pendant la remédiation
accompagne l'entreprise mais sans
intervenir et nous allons contrôler à la
fin de la remédiation que le niveau de
sécurité obtenu est celui que la drsd
attend
les entreprises de labilité des sont
menacées de la même manière que les
autres en revanche il y a effectivement
des pépites des pépites industrielles en
France qui disposent de technologies ou
qui créent qui développent des
applications particulières ou qui
développent des technologies
particulières jusqu'à des matériaux
particuliers celle-là sont
potentiellement victimes d'attaque et là
il s'agit plutôt
de fuite de données donc le l'attaque
vise à
extorquer le l'entreprise et à lui
piller toutes les données sensibles dont
elles dispose des savoir-faire rares
comme celui de cette entreprise clé de
la défense inquiète face à la menace
cyber elle préfère témoigner anonymement
du soutien qu'elle reçoit de la drsd
généralement quand on fait appel à
l'armée ils interviennent dans la
journée et le gros avantage c'est qu'en
fait on peut discuter avec eux sur les
éléments qu'on a déjà trouvé ils vont
plus loin en termes d'analyse et ils
nous font justement une analyse complète
et nous permet de répondre à la question
est-ce qu'on a été ou pas compromis et
si on a été compromis quels sont les
actions à mener pour pouvoir justement
stopper cette compromission dans un
cyberespace en perpétuel évolution
l'innovation tient une place cruciale
en 2019 le ministère des armées lance la
cyber défense Factory une couveuse
d'entreprise ouverte société qui se
lancent dans le domaine
la start-up Gims créez la même année par
4 anciens ingénieurs de la Direction
générale de l'armement et la toute
première entreprise à la rejoindre son
projet débusquer les virus
au départ de notre activité c'est un
algorithme de à base de Deep learning
sur lequel on a travaillé qu'on appelle
nous la conceptualisation de code alors
à quoi est-ce que ça correspond un petit
peu comme le cerveau humain lorsqu'il
voit par exemple une photo de fleurs ou
lorsqu'il entend le mot fleur il est
capable de relier ça au concept de la
fleur et du coup le comparer le
mémoriser le relier éventuellement à
d'autres concepts c'est quelque chose
qu'on s'est fait aujourd'hui avec des
deep learning ça parce qu'on s'est
reproduire le mécanisme du cerveau
humain le réseau numéro du cerveau
humain dans le principe même de la
conceptualisation et donc ce qu'on a
fait chez limp c'est qu'on a entraîné un
moteur de Deep learning non pas à
regarder des fleurs évidemment mais à
lire du code informatique des logiciels
informatiques et cet algorithme de Deep
learning il nous a permis de détecter
des codes malveillants par exemple sur
la base de leurs concept on va être
capable de voir des variants de virus
informatique et les détecter un
algorithme qui doit permettre
d'optimiser la réaction face à une
cyberattaque les derniers exemples qu'on
a eu sur les attaques c'est 4 heures
entre le 1er mail d'infection initiale
et les premières machines qui ont été
paralysées par le virus donc en quatre
heures l'analyse il a besoin d'être
capable de détecter et d'avoir
suffisamment d'informations à ce
moment-là pour réagir de manière à thé
et savoir est-ce qu'il faut isoler un
poste est-ce qu'il faut couper le réseau
est-ce qu'il faut éteindre tout le
système éventuellement là avec nos
outils on va pouvoir à peine quelques
secondes quelques dizaines de secondes
pour lesquelles les plus extrêmes
identifier l'intégralité des cotes qui
sont au sein d'un malware l'intégralité
des codes connus en tout cas ce qui va
permettre à l'analyse de se concentrer
sur sa vraie plus-value c'est-à-dire le
code mal vu en lui-même pour savoir ce
qu'il va pouvoir faire
dans un domaine cyber en pleine
expansion le ministère des armées offre
des perspectives pour exercer des
métiers variés la loi de programmation
militaire 2019-2025 accroît les efforts
fait avec un budget 1,6 milliards
d'euros et un effectif de 5000
spécialistes civils et militaires d'ici
[Musique]